Derick Pitts is the chief astronomer and
planetarium director for the Franklin
Institute that's in Philadelphia Pitts
and his team from the Institute will
observe the Eclipse from Saint Joseph
Missouri that's within a 70 mile wide
path of totality so that's a good spot
he joins us now from rosecrans Memorial
Airport this morning
hello Derek Pitts good morning good
morning how is everybody there no the
better question is how are you listen
when Lonnie Quinn was here he told us
it's like Christmas in August
michio kaku says he's expecting a
spiritual experience so I'm wondering
for you what excites you most are you
feeling all tingly today well I'm really
excited about what's going to happen
here today I'm looking forward to seeing
totality anytime I have the opportunity
to stand in the shadow of the moon I'm
happy and today I'll get two minutes and
39 seconds of an ice bath of moon shadow
this is the first coast-to-coast solar
eclipse in 99 years
what can scientist astronomers learn
from today what astronomers are hoping
to learn from today during totality is a
little bit more about the corona of the
Sun the corona of the Sun is that outer
atmosphere that's so very very thin and
tenuous this is what we see during
totality that pearly glow of sort of
like atmosphere around the Sun and the
corona is incredibly hot millions of
degrees and astronomers don't understand
completely why the corona is so hot
given that the surface of the Sun is
just about 11,000 degrees so looking to
understand that also looking to
understand more about magnetic fields on
the Sun and this also gives us an
opportunity to get a little bit better
idea shall we say refine our
measurements of the orbital velocity of
the moon as it goes around the earth
because during an eclipse you can use
that as an opportunity to get a better
measure of that aside from all of what's
going on in the sky everyone will be
looking up I understand there's this
thing called shadow snakes or shadow
bands on the ground right before
totality it's some have described it
like thousands of snakes going in the
same direction explain this
yes shadow bands are these it's really
interesting phenomena that happens just
before totality and just after totality
and what you
actually see on the ground are these
rippling lines of light and dark like
shadows and light rippling along the
ground and this is caused by
interference of different temperature
air cells in the Earth's atmosphere with
the light from the Sun coming through
but only at the point where it's just
before totality other than that you
don't see it now these are rare and hard
to capture so that's part of my
particular interest is seeing if we can
see these shadow bands because they are
so rare but it'll be really really cool
to see them especially because it only
can happen during a total solar eclipse
and you have to you can't see it
anywhere else so you can't go out to
space and see it or something like that
you can only see it on the ground right
around you when it's just about to occur
totally well Derek I just want to point
out that you personally gave about eight
thousand glasses for people to look at
this today you get big good guy points
for that clearly that was important for
you to do Thank You Derek thank you very
much bye